[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai choisi d'enseigner parce que je
crois profondément que la musique
structure nos jeunes et cet enseignant
de Magog c'est une chance de d'avoir un
grand local tout équipé ce qui est loin
d'être le cas partout j'ai des collègues
qui sont sur des chariots pour enseigner
la musique vous comprenez que ça limite
l'accès aux instruments pour les enfants
parce que la musique relève du choix de
chaque école c'est pas de matière
obligatoire c'est qu'on doit justifier
notre place une école peut décider de
couper dans les heures d'enseignement de
la musique peut ne pas offrir de locaux
de musique finalement ne pas ne pas
donner les conditions gagnantes pour que
l'enseignement de la musique soit
efficace
à l'UQAM Isabelle Hérault forment ceux
et celles qui vont enseigner la guitare
en milieu scolaire
pour elle c'est aussi important
d'enseigner la musique que l'éducation
physique aux élèves
d'ailleurs maintenant le Ministère de
l'Éducation prescrit le temps qu'il faut
allouer à l'activité physique
[Musique]
il y a une période de l'histoire du
Québec où on a imposé l'enseignement de
la musique dans les écoles c'était
obligatoire depuis les années 80 les
règles du jeu ont été modifiées
ce qui est requis aujourd'hui c'est
l'enseignement des arts en musique
évidemment c'est plus une plage or qui
est là et nous partageons la plage avec
d'autres de mes collègues en or en
plastique en automatique danse musique
ces trois membres de la Fédération des
musiciens éducateurs du Québec
s'inquiète de l'avenir de la musique à
l'école publique
difficile d'appuyer leur crainte avec
des données centralisées le ministère de
l'Éducation répond qu'en raison du choix
éducatif local il n'y a pas de données
sur le nombre d'écoles qui enseigne la
musique au Québec on a fait une sondage
en 2018 et puis il y a
60% des profs qui disent qu'ils
enseignent pas leur minimale prescrit
par le ministère il y a quelquefois des
enseignants de musique qui apprennent
que oups leur période de musique sera
coupée pour l'année suivante au lieu
d'enseigner une heure ce sera une
demi-heure par semaine
Sylvain Caron se sent à l'abri de cet
arbitraire pour le moment à l'école
secondaire Dorval Jean 23 il jouit de
l'appui de sa direction du centre de
service scolaire Marguerite Bourgeois et
des parents de plus on a remplacé la
piscine vétuste qu'il fallait démolir
par un département de musique comme il y
en a peu tout cela rend l'option musique
beaucoup plus attrayante pour les élèves
moi je préfère la musique les autres
options comme art dramatique ou arts
plastiques quelque chose qui est bonifié
le développement global de l'élève c'est
vrai que la musique sculpte le cerveau
envoie des Omega le lien entre la
musique et le cerveau c'est la
spécialité d'Isabelle Perrette à
l'Université de Montréal plus on est
dans des écoles défavorisées plus ça
devrait être structuré
et rendu accessible pourvu que tu joues
ici au bon moment tu fais partie du
groupe la musique est un élément de
cohésion très fort puis la recherche le
prouve
à l'automne la Fédération des musiciens
éducateurs doit déposer un livre blanc
Québec pour défendre la place de la
musique à l'école
ici Anne-Louise despaty Radio-Canada
Montréal